>>Narrator: They are where
Maine seventh-graders are,
in the classroom, at
home and in the field.
In September of 2002, some 19,000
shiny, new laptops were placed
in the hands of Maine's
middle-schoolers and their teachers.
It was the beginning
of a bold experiment
that may revolutionize public
education, an initiative born
of a rare budget surplus and the
vision of former Governor Angus King.
>>Angus: This idea was basically
to make our people the most
digitally literate society on Earth.
>>Teacher: Attach that
to me in an e-mail.
>>Angus: You cannot grasp the power
of this idea until you go into one
of these seventh-grade classrooms,
where there are 20 kids there all
with their iBooks open and the
teacher's wandering around up
and down the aisles and the
kids are all doing this stuff,
and you can almost hear, "Eureka!"
>>Teacher: So, what's another
crustacean that you know?
>>Student: A lobster.
>>Teacher: Yes, they're related
to lobsters, these are...
>>Angus: One of the
most powerful parts
of this idea is that it's everybody.
Is it an equity tool.
>>Teacher: Somebody
just take care of that.
>>Narrator: Using their laptops,
students have decided worlds
of knowledge beyond the classroom.
These students from
Nobleboro Central School are
on a daylong research field trip
with the Maine Lakes
Conservancy Institute.
>>Shippen: Today we've been working
with the Nobleboro Central School,
where we've been out on the lake
on our mobile floating classroom,
the Melinda Anne, where
the kids have been engaging
in hands-on experiential lake science
education using different science
equipment, and they will take
this data back to the classroom,
where they have put it into their
laptops, and they will load it
onto the Students Portal
section of the MLCI's Web site,
where the kids feature their lake,
their community, to show the world.
>>Student: These are the
old traffic jams, bugs.
>>Shippen: We start with
developing a sense of wonder,
and there's two criteria
we have for any piece
of equipment that comes on the boat.
One, it has to have a basis
in the science; and, two,
it's got to have the
"oh, cool" factor.
If we don't get an "oh, cool" out
of the kids within 30 seconds,
that equipment's out of there,
because we've only got about an hour
and a half, 2 hours with
them, and what we want
to do is really get their
sense of wonder going,
because that generates the questions,
which leads to new knowledge.
>>Wow, that is a huge daphnia.
See if you can zero in on that.
>>One of the things that
we were looking for was:
How do we make these laptops more
than just a $2,000.00 pencil?
What is the transformative
educational value of these laptops,
and our Students Portal is that.
>>Narrator: Back in the classroom,
students organize the data
and photos they gathered in the
field and write descriptions
of their findings that will be
placed on the conservancy's Web site.
>>Student: They look
sort of like puffer fish.
>>Mary Ann: Puffer fish, they do,
that's kind of a good analogy.
>>I think that hands-on, multisensory
is really what gets them fired up.
They own it.
They've experienced it.
So then to come back to the
classroom and start playing
with that information and
how to make that enticing
so other people will want to read
it, I think they get really jazzed
up about that, because
they're being inventors.
They're being creators, and
then it's changing the way
that learning happens.
>>Student: The first one was better.
>>Narrator: The laptops are
also changing the way teaching
happens here.
>>Teacher: So, listen, here we go.
Walk me through, because
you guys are the experts.
>>Student: You edit.
>>Teacher: We've got to go
down to "Edit Project," right?
>>Angus: One of the crucial
elements of our project was
that we took the time and the
money from the outset to work
with the teachers before dropping
the hardware on the desks,
because if you just give every kid
a computer, it ain't going to work.
This is a fundamentally
different way to teach,
to get at information,
to present information.
The integration of the Internet
into the daily curriculum is the
next big educational challenge.
>>Ken: Microscopic blue-green algae.
>>Narrator: For science teacher
Ken Williams, using the laptops
to exploit Internet resources
has been a liberating experience.
>>Ken: Say, "Here's the loon
assignment from my dad."
Go.
>>Student: Here's the loon
assignment from my dad.
>>Ken: Good, beautiful,
now let me go see...
>>I actually have worked less this
year and kids have worked more,
because I've done less talking
and they've done more finding,
and it's absolutely
happened that way.
>>Student: We can find
things out for ourselves.
You can just say, "All
right, everybody.
Search Google and try and find
some information about this," or,
"Let's go out on the boat and find
these little bugs and take pictures
of them to display on the
Internet," or something like that.
It's just more interesting that we
can find things out for ourselves.
I think you're learning more that
way than reading about it in a book.
>>Ken: They're seeing
the whole picture.
They're seeing how a little worm
can get plopped on the Internet
for somebody else to see that,
and I think there's going
to be this great rippling effect
of information and stewardship.
I think that's the goal.
>>Narrator: At King
Middle School in Portland,
students create digital products
that demonstrate the
depth of their learning.
One class recently worked with the
local Audubon Society to produce
"Fading Footprints," a CD-ROM
that catalogues several
of Maine's endangered species.
Each student picked an animal
and created original artwork
and written descriptions that
required extensive research.
>>Student: We were also using our
library and many books that tried
to find some information on Internet.
We use our laptops a lot,
that was the big help.
>>David: What used to happen is
you'd have to go down to the library
and you'd read and you'd take your
notes on a separate piece of paper
and then you'd take all your
notes and put them on cards
and then you'd go and you'd
build something from them
in your English class, and now
you're doing this whole gathering
of information and expressing it and
representing it at the same time.
And so what happens is kids
are working with information,
more information they've
ever seen before
in a much more immediate
and gratifying way.
>>Student: Land, that's
like geography.
>>Student: That's geography.
>>David: The laptops come with
an amazing set of applications
that allow kids to work with so many
different kinds of ways of thinking.
>>Student: We're linking to sort
of make sure that each page goes
to the correct other
page, like if you clicked
on "documentary video" it would
really go to the documentary video.
And then everyone's
pages had to be linked.
>>Student: It took a long time.
>>Student: But once
you got the hang of it,
it sort of all connects all together.
>>Seymour: These kids
are more engaged.
These kids are coming to school
more promptly, they are talking
at home more about what
they did at school.
>>Narrator: As a prime mover
of the laptop initiative,
Seymour Papert is encouraged
by what he has seen
in the first year of the program.
>>Student: This year my
grades were a lot better.
I think it was because of laptops,
because I was doing better
work and was more interested.
>>Seymour: Does it make
it harder or easier?
>>Student: Sometimes it's easier
and sometimes it's harder.
>>Seymour: Which do you prefer?
>>Student: Well, I like it harder,
because then I'm learning more.
>>Student: Sometimes our teachers
make our projects harder and things,
because we have our laptops to
access information and stuff.
>>Seymour: It's lovely seeing that
it's taking on this excitement,
but I keep on insisting
it is just a first step.
In the course of time,
people will see
that they can do very different
stuff in school, and what's great
about the situation here
is what it could grow
into that goes beyond what is
happening in many other places
where there are computers.
>>David: The title for
the laptop initiative,
as far as I like to remember,
is called "Maine Learns,"
and the learning is about how
to work with other people.
It's about how to get
teachers and kids
to re-imagine what the classroom
is and to apply that knowledge
and to take it to someplace new,
but the main thing is the seed
of change is the computer,
and it's right there.
Everybody's got it.
They know they've got to use
it, and, boy, is it happening.
>>Teacher: You guys
are right on the money.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.